um so come come comic-con is a 150,000
people descending on San Diego and I'm
going to be in the middle of it come the
people of comic-con setting a compound
have been kind enough to give us a panel
we're going to be having a panel it's
going to be actors when we have in the
show it's been give producers the
directors the riders it's going to be me
of course it's going to be in fact
there's even gonna be an executive from
Kickstarter on the candle with us
talking my Kickstarter it's going to be
she's flying in from New York and it's
going to be great and will be able to
meet meet our fans and talked and we're
going to also show some footage that
we've never shown before we're going to
unveil some exclusive footage f camp at
comic-con and then the next day we're
going to be doing a signing where we're
going to have an exclusive poster there
were any signing to a whole bunch of
people and and we're gonna you know we
wearing our Space Command t-shirt it
said and go into town and we're going to
have a party where we're going to have
you know with the countdown because we
are our Space Command Kickstarter
campaign ends Saturday night you know
midnight New York time 9pm a hard time
so we're going to have a countdown we're
going to have all of our friends there
and all of our fans want to come and
we're going to be in a big room and
we're going to be cheering and shouting
and you know looking to see how high
that number gets you know tell tell your
friends tell your family tell your
grandma you know and it's gonna grade
what's the exacting the date is the
panel is july 13thfriday July thirteenth
room 5 a and B it's 830-930 p.m. and our
campaign ends the next days saturday
july nine th july fourteenth saturday
july fourteenth
the same time midnight Easter time and
it's really great and did you schedule I
mean did you plan your campaign around
compound as you know that was a part
away don't we started our campaign on
coast to coast which is this radio show
that I go in every few months and it has
a huge listenership 5 million people
right George Noory and we've actually
cast him in Space Command he's gonna
play a character which is there he told
me that someone said he would be
reincarnated as a talk show hosting
Dexter Monterey so we've actually put
that character in Space Command haha
it's gonna be great fun and so we
started with that and then when he was
Tom console the idea was that to anchor
the campaign at the beginning of the at
the end so because again it's you know
what's gonna get attention was going to
get noticed what's going to bang the
drum because I feel enormously confident
look I'm if I weren't doing Space
Command I would be thrilled to be
watching Space Command it would be
something I mean you know I was first in
line to see Prometheus I'm I know what I
am I know there's millions of people
like me and so you know so I so I'm
thrilled to be creating something that's
exciting to me and millions of people
and you know and that's just an
obligation of doing it because the
challenge is doing it for a long number
you know $100,000 sounds like a lot of
money than anyone but to make a movie
let alone a series of films it's it's a
challenge and if I didn't have the
friends I have we're geniuses that
special effects genius as a production
genius actors you know it's because of
the people i know that makes me
confident i can do this you know if I
was just starting out I would never
attempt something like this would be
impossible to deliver something with
this amount of effects and this amount
of this scope on this budget no but I
know I can do it because I know
what I've done and I know who my friends
are so it's cool it seems like you've
been almost wedding in whole life for
this region do I have a pulse I have I
mean everything I've done all the
hundreds of hours of television all the
books all day everything all the people
I've met you know it's very gratifying
to be the Damon Lindelof and Guillermo
and all of these dear friends and show
runners and a list people are in favor
of what i'm doing and backing what i'm
doing Brandon Bragg it just said that he
wants to donate to our campaign Brandon
comes up star trekkin 24 and you know
terranova you know these are these are
friends and pets very nice to see their
faith in me cuz they have confidence
that I can pull this off and I'm frankly
I do too you know it's it's that that's
the other part of it um I wouldn't
undertake this I didn't didn't know if I
could do it and do it wonderfully and so
I'm chomping at the bit I can't wait and
I'm actually we're not waiting on ride
I'm writing the scripts and and and
we're building sets in building space
suits and you know Ian MacKaye who
designed Darth Maul and Queen Amidala is
aboard he's designing aliens and
characters and so we're not good then it
was a different question whether we do
this or not the only thing i didn't know
as if we could raise the money on
kickstarter but i was determined make
this regardless you know if it was a
matter of you know i'm doing it on you
know get a job at a restaurant and
taking tips and you know making it off
tips you know what whatever works you
know and we were gonna make this no
matter what
and I'm so grateful everyone is helping
us make
you